GREG: THE NEWS SEEMS PRETTY GOOD
IF YOU ASK ME.
BOOMING ECONOMY, UNLIMITED
DROPPING A NEW SUPREME COURT
JUDGE WHO CAN STAY AWAKE.
PIECES BREAKING OUT IN THE
CAREERS AND AMERICAN PASTORS
RELEASE FROM TURKEY AND I JUST
SAW MICHAEL DOWNTOWN SELLING
PENCILS.
HE IS SO ADORABLE IN CARDBOARD
SHORTS.
YET, IN TWO YEARS TRUMP SALT
MORE HEADACHES THAN A BOATLOAD
OF [INAUDIBLE].
SHOULD YOU BELIEVE THE POLLS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I BELIEVE IN
POLLS.
ONLY THE ONES THAT HAVE US UP.
OTHER THAN THAT THERE ARE THE
FAKE NEWS POLLS.
GREG: I THINK THAT MADE SENSE.
THIS GREAT NEWS CAN MEAN ONE
ROAD FOR THE MEDIA.
KEEP LOOKING FOR THE BAD MATTER
HOW FAR BACK YOU GOT TO GO.
CHECK OUT THIS HEADLINE FROM THE
HOLLYWOOD REPORTER ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP'S SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR,
STEVEN MULLER AND MILLER'S THIRD
GRADE TEACHER SAID HE WAS A
LONER AND EIGHT GLUE.
[LAUGHTER]
HOLY [BLEEP].
SERIOUSLY.
THAT'S A REAL HEADLINE.
APPARENTLY MULLER WOULD DRY GLUE
AND EAT IT.
MULLER WAS LIKE EVERY OTHER
[BLEEP] THIRD GRADER.
THE TEACHER HAS BEEN SUSPENDED
FOR LEAKING THIS VALUABLE INFO
AND I HOPE SHE IS HOME MAKING A
SCRAPBOOK WITH A POTTER OF
ELDERS BY HER SIDE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHO IS WORSE?
THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER.
FIERCELY HOW FAR HAVE YOU
STRAIGHT FROM YOUR MISSION AS A
MOVIE INDUSTRY RACK TO DO THE
STORY.
HOW IS EATING GLUE HOLLYWOOD
NEEDS?
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE YOUR NEXT
SCOOP AS AN UNBORN BABY, MIKE
POMPEO, ONCE KICKED HIS MOM IN
THE WOMB.
[LAUGHTER]
HOW MUCH DO YOU WANT TO BET THE
TEACHER IS A DEMOCRAT IS AN
THEIR BEHAVIOR IS SO IRRATIONAL
IT'S PERMITTED.
ASK THE PANTSUIT.
>> YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL WITH A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR AND
WHAT YOU CARE ABOUT.
GREG: THAT IS FUNNY.
I DON'T SEEM TO REMEMBER HER
BEING CIVIL TO MONICA, JUANITA
OR PAULA.
IS THIS THE RIGHT TIME FOR HER
TO LECTURE US ON CIVILITY?
HER PARTY JUST RUINED A MAN AND
SHE TELLS US WE ARE UNCIVIL.
THAT'S RUNNING OVER MY DOG AND
BILLING ME FOR THE BURIAL.
[LAUGHTER]
BY THE WAY, HILLARY AND BILL ARE
GOING ON A TOUR TOGETHER.
SHE WANTS TO MAKE MONEY AND HE
WANTS TO MAKE IT TO THE R IN HIS
LITTLE BLACK BOOK.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE WANTS TO PAY FOR THE SECOND
RENOVATION OF THEIR THIRD HOME
AND HE WANTS TO HAVE A FOURSOME
WITH TRIPLETS IN A DUPLEX.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT CREATES 24 DIFFERENT
COMMENDATIONS.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU CAN BET BILL HAS DONE THE
MATH.
NOW, IT'S ABOUT WHICH SIDE IS
MORE UNCIVIL.
IF YOU BRING UP THE LEFT,
LIBERAL SCREAM WHAT ABOUT TRUMP
HE IS SO ME.
MY JOB TODAY IS TO COMPARE THE
UNCIVIL BEHAVIOR OF BOTH THE
LEFT AND RIGHT.
FIRST, THE LEFT.
YOU HAVE THE SCHOOL LISA
SHOOTING AND CAMPUS SPEECH
SHUTDOWNS AND ANTI- FA AND
REMEMBER MADONNA AND JOHNNY
DEPP?
PEOPLE CHASED FROM RESTAURANTS.
KATHY GRIFFIN.
MOBS CHATTING ABOUT WANTING
DESKTOPS AND THAT IS A LOT.
IT'S NOT A BUG IN THE SYSTEM BUT
THAT'S THE WHOLE DAMN SYSTEM.
WHAT WE HAVE ON THE RIGHT?
THIS GUY.
BOAT LEAKING DIANE FEINSTEIN,
CROOKED HILLARY, FAKE NEWS,
SLEEPY EYES CHUCK IS A SLEEPING
SON OF A BI TCH.
GREG: SO HE'S CRASS AND ROUGH
AND RUDE BUT NO COMPARISON BUT
JUST WORDS.
ONCE WHILE WE DO GET A WACKO
DOING WACKO [BLEEP] BUT OUR
FRIENDSHIP STAYS RANGE.
WE DO NOT HAVE THEM OVER FOR
DINNER.
DEMS HAVE A BIGGER PROBLEM.
THEY ARE HATEFUL FACTIONS TRYING
TO SCARE YOU INTO ACCEPTING
THEIR DEMANDS.
I CALLED THEM A MOB BUT THEN THE
MEDIA MIGHT COLLAPSE.
>> TED CRUZ GETTING CHASED OUT
OF RESTAURANTS BY A MOB.
>> YOU WILL NOT USE THE MOB WORD
HERE.
>> IT IS TOTALLY A MOB.
>> STOP.
STOP.
>> THAT IS MY BEHAVIOR.
>> EVERYBODY STOP.
MATT, WE ALREADY DID THAT.
WE SAID THEY WERE NOT MOBS.
>> IF WE WERE A TEA PARTY YOU
CALL IT A MOB FOR SURE.
BE SERIOUS LET ME MOVE PAST THE
M WORD.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: IT'S THE M WORD NOW.
IT IS FUNNY HOW THEY RESPOND IN
THING.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE AN M WORD.
WHEN YOU ENABLE GROUP AS AN
UNBENDING AND INTUITIVE FORCE
YOU GET A MOB.
IT IS NOT NEW.
LEFT-WING BELIEF IS NEARING THE
PERSONAL TO THE POLITICAL IN
ORDER TO MOBILIZE AND DEMONIZE.
IF THEY CONSIDER YOU EVIL THERE
JUSTIFIED IN DOING THIS.
>> BECAUSE I TOLD YOU TO.
>> YEAH, YOU LITTLE WHITE
[BLEEP].
YOU ARE A WHITEY, AREN'T YOU?
GREG: YOU KNOW THAT GUY LIVES ON
SOMEONE'S COUCH.
AND HE HAS AN ENTIRE MICROBIAL
CIVILIZATION LIVING IN HIS PANT
PANTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AND HE IS WHITE.
GREG: THAT'S JUST ONE OF HIS
PROBLEM.
ALL THIS GOOD NEWS IS MAKING THE
PEOPLE NOT.
REALLY THEY NEED TO TAKE IT OUT
ON SOMETHING.
>> TOM, GOING TO THE PROTEST
THIS WEEKEND?
>> I'M OUT.
I CAN'T MISS ANOTHER GAME.
>> MAYBE NEXT LINE.
>> YEAH.
DON'T GET ME WRONG, I'M AN ANGRY
LIBERAL BUT I AM EXHAUSTED.
KEEPS WINNING.
I WISH THERE WAS AN EASIER WAY
TO FIGHT BACK.
>> THERE IS NOT WITH RAGE
PILLOW.
SQUEEZE IT AND LET YOUR
FRUSTRATIONS OUT.
IT IS SO CONVENIENT YOU CAN TAKE
IT ANYWHERE.
GET ANGRY AT THE OFFICE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
>> YOU TAKE CREDIT FOR
EVERYTHING.
>> YOU FOR HOLDING.
I WAS ON ANOTHER CALL.
>> AT A RESTAURANT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: HORRENDOUS
PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD --
>> YOU ARE KILLING MOTHER ELVES.
>> EVEN AT THE MOVIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: CROOKED
HILLARY.
>> SHE WON THE POPULAR VOTE.
ABOLISH THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
>> ORDER NOW AND WE THROW IN THE
BLOWUP PILOT FROM AIRPLANE.
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE, TAKE BACK
YOUR LIFE FIRST WITH RAGE
PILLOW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE WIN SO MUCH
WILL GET TIRED OF WINNING.
>> STOP WINNING.
[SCREAMING]
GREG: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT
GUESTS.
WHENEVER YOU ARE YOU TO BE LOOK
FOR DAVE RUBIN.
CREATOR AND HOST AND YOU CAN
STILL THAT OF THE RUBIN REPORT.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS SO BRIGHT LIGHT HOUSES
LOOK FOR HER IN A STORM, NEW
BOOK IS CALLED # DO NOT DISTURB,
JEDEDIAH.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS TRIM, GRIM AND LIGHT OF
LIM, NATIONAL REVIEW REPORTER
KAT SINCE.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND THE EIFFEL TOWER IS A TOWEL
RACK FORMULA WWE SUPERSTAR AND
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK TYRUS.
WHO IS HIGH.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
DATE YOUR CLASSICAL LIBERAL.
GREG: SO I WILL TURN YOU INTO
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOUR PARTY
QUESTION.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> DID I HEAR THAT CORRECTLY,
LEAKING DIANE FEINSTEIN?
LEAKING LIKE HE REALLY IS GOOD
AT THIS.
GREG: IT CONJURES UP TWO
DIFFERENT LEAKS.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> LOOK, THIS IS WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF YOU RAN AROUND FOR
YEARS SCREAMING THAT EVERYONE OF
YOU GUYS AND EVIL PEOPLE ON BOX
WERE ALL RACIST AND BIGOTS AND
HOMOPHOBES.
THE ENDGAME WAS GOING TO BE THAT
YOU'D END UP USING VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE PEOPLE AND CONDONING
IT.
THESE GUYS CALL THEMSELVES
INTIFADA AND THEY ARE THE FAR.
THEY LITERALLY DRESS LIKE
SOLDIERS COVERT SOLDIERS FROM
G.I. JOE AND THINK THEY ARE THE
GOOD GUYS.
SOMETHING IS SERIOUSLY WRONG.
GREG: I LIKE THAT THEY SELF
APPOINTED THEMSELVES AS CROSSING
GUARDS.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS THE FIRST STEP.
>> AND THE TYPE OF MENTAL
DISORDER TO BE A WHITE PERSON
SCREAMING AT ANOTHER WHITE
PERSON OVER HIS WHITENESS.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT THEY MODERN MENTAL DISORDE
DISORDER.
GREG: TIRES, I SAW YOU
PRACTICALLY LEAVE OUT OF YOUR
COMFORTABLE CHAIR WHEN YOU HEARD
THE M WORD.
TYRUS: I WAS LIKE WHAT WORD?
WHITE PEOPLE ARE ATTACKING EACH
OTHER, THE NEW M WORD.
NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME TO BE
BLACK.
[LAUGHTER]
WE MADE IT.
SORRY.
LIKE, I HAVE NEVER SEEN A WHITE
GUY TALK TO A WHITE GUY LIKE
THAT.
THAT IS HURTFUL.
THAT SUCKS FOR HIM TO BE WHITE.
AND TO BE TALKED TO LIKE THAT BY
ANOTHER WIDER GUY, ACTUALLY.
WHAT IS THAT?
WHITE ON WHITE VIOLENCE.
GREG: IT IS.
TYRUS: IT'S AMAZING THAT -- I
NEVER HAD THOSE ISSUES AT A
CROSSWALK.
I'VE NEVER HAD SOMEONE HEY, GO
THIS WAY OR TURN THAT WAY.
A PICK THE GUY WHO LOOKS A
LITTLE LIKE YOU A LITTLE BIT.
GREG: I KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
GOING.
TYRUS: BARELY SEES OVER THE
STEERING WHEEL.
LET'S GO PICK ON THAT KID.
GREG: YOU ARE HEIGHT SHAMING.
TYRUS: I AM CAR SHAMING.
THEY NEED TO MAKE HIGHER DEEDS.
GREG: THIS WILL NEVER HAPPEN TO
ME.
YOU ARE MAKING A GREAT POINT AND
I FORGOT WHAT IT WAS.
IT HAD TO DO WITH -- THESE TWO
NETFLIX EMPLOYS CHASED BRIAN
KILMEADE, HE WAS LEAVING HIS
AGENT AND THEY CHASED HIM DOWN
TO A SUBWAY AND WENT TO THE
SUBWAY AND THEY INCITED THE
PEOPLE IN THE SUBWAY TO TARGET
HIM.
THEY WON'T DO THAT TO YOU, TYRU
TYRUS.
TYRUS: ESPECIALLY IF THEY CHASE
ME INTO A SUBWAY.
I'M LURING THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
IF YOU GET IN A SUBWAY WITH ME
IN THE DOORWAY CLOSE, THAT'S
YOUR ASS.
NOT MINE.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: JEDEDIAH, I WILL DEFEND
PEOPLE OUT OF POWER FOR THEIR
DESIRE TO EXPRESS RAGE BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THE LEFT IS EXPECTED
RATE WEATHER IN OR OUT OF POWER.
>> THEY ARE ALWAYS MAD ABOUT
SOMETHING.
YOU CAN EXPRESS RAGE WE CAN'T
DESTROY PROPERTY OR GO OUT THERE
AND THEY DEFEND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND I DEFEND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT BUT YOU CAN'T DESTROY
BUSINESSES AND GET IN PEOPLE'S
FACES IN RESTAURANTS AND DRIVE
THEM OUT OF SPACES.
I PAID TO BREAK IT BUT THAT'S
THE DEFINITION OF A MOB.
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE THAT MAKE LIFE
INCREDIBLY DIFFERENT UNDER
DIFFICULT AND THEY ARE
IN-YOUR-FACE.
IT'S SO CRAZY TO ME BECAUSE YOU
ARE SEEING THESE PEOPLE IN MOST
MEDIA OUTLETS AND THEY REVEAL
THEMSELVES TO BE WHO THEY ARE.
YOUR FINGERS THAT ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE MARTYRING THE DEBATES AND
THEY ARE SO MAD AND SO DEFENSIVE
BECAUSE TRUMP ONE AND THEY'RE
STILL MAD ABOUT IT NOW THEY HAVE
TO DEFEND THIS MOB THAT THEY'RE
COMPELLED TO JUMP IN AND THEY
ARE ON THE PARTISAN SIDE.
GREG: THEY ARE NOT MODERATING.
>> IT IS CRAZY.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
TEACHER BUT YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE MOP?
KAT: CAN DISCUSS WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
I AM VERY VERSATILE.
GREG: SURPRISINGLY.
KAT: I CAN DO BOTH QUICKLY.
I CAN SAY FIRST OF ALL, NO JUDGE
ON EATING GLUE.
WHEN I WAS A CHILD I USED TO
LOVE TO EAT THE DELICIOUS ROCK
RESULTS THAT THEY USE TO MELT
THE SNOW.
GREG: YES, YES.
KAT: AND I WAS QUITE POPULAR IN
THE THIRD GRADE.
AS FOR THE MOB MENTALITY IT WAS
NOT JUST HILLARY CLINTON BUT
ERIC HOLDER SAYING WHEN THEY GO
LOW, KICK THEM.
NOT ONLY IS THAT NOT NICE BUT
ALSO NOT VERY EFFECTIVE AS IF
I'M ON THE GROUND AND SOMEONE IS
KICKING ME I'M NOT GOING TO BE
THINKING I WOULD LOVE TO
THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDER THIS
PERSON'S VIEWS ON HEALTHCARE AND
IMMIGRATION.
I'M THINKING WHY IS THIS [BLEEP]
KICKING ME AND SO IF THEY REALLY
WANT TO HAVE THESE MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE ABOUT ISSUES AND MAKE A
CHANGE THEN YOU HAVE TO BE CIVI
CIVIL.
GREG: HAVE TO MOVE ON BUT I
STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND SOMEONE
FROM THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER
CALLED ME AND TOMMY WHY YOU
WOULD DO THAT'S RIGHT WHEN YOU
CALL THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER AND
YOU'RE A MOVIE INDUSTRY JOURNAL.